moi je la crise et des défis suis ma
part qui m'ont contacté en vain quelques
organes il doit concours c'est les
fausses pages notamment des informations
personnelles pour aller chercher des
informations bancaires
enfin concours bidon pour gagner 1000
dollars
infoconcert des duels ou encore la
promesse de pouvoir visionner
gratuitement un film toujours à
l'affiché au cinéma ces propositions
bien différente comportant toutes le
même but vous amener vers cette page
d'inscription qui propose un essai
gratuit en échange de vos informations
de carte de crédit
depuis plus d'une décennie cette arnaque
pullulent sur la toile
mais pour la première fois nous avons
découvert que plusieurs de ces concours
concerts et diffusion bidons sont
l'oeuvre de sous traitants d'une société
montréalaise nommé at center et que ces
fausses promesses certes à appâter les
internautes vers les sites web d'une
autre entreprise
nommé à yuna internationaux situés à la
barbade
ces deux compagnies sont liées à la même
personne
l'homme d'affaires montréalais philippe
qu'ils aient les internautes qui se font
prendre au piège sur les sites de rai
uno la chesnaie sont rapidement déçu de
l'autre côté du formulaire d'inscription
le concert où le film promis n'existe
pas il retrouve plutôt une librairie
multi media composer notamment d'oeuvre
inconnu ou libres de droits pour ceux
qui oublient de se désabonner l'essai
gratuit se transforme rapidement en
forfait pouvant coûter jusqu'à 64
dollars par mois
les montants perçus auprès des clients
individuels ne sont pas énormes mais nos
recherches démontrent qu'ils sont des
milliers à se faire flouer partout à
travers le monde avec ce stratagème
lampe est relié à philippe qu'ils
génèrent des dizaines de millions de
dollars par année
la plupart des cham frauduleux au cours
des années se sont tous ont un peu
raffiné je dirais on a réalisé que si on
va avoir plus de chances de succès il
faut y aller avec des petits montants
mais y aller au volume les activités
data center ne sont pas illégal en soi
mais celle de ses sous-traitants
pourraient l'être des avocats
spécialisés nous disent que leurs
publicités trompeuses et l'impression
générale de gratuité que dégagent les
sites web de rai uno nationaux
pourraient contrevenir à la loi
canadienne sur la concurrence
philippe qui eux n'a pas donné suite à
notre demande d'entrevue
mais un avocat représentant a ction
milliards autre nom pour à 100 heures
nous a répondu que l'entreprise ni est
vigoureusement toutes les allégations et
que les allégations contenues dans notre
reportage sont fausses ou trompeuses et
carrément diffamatoire nicolas de rose à
radio canada montréal